jackie robinson day around major league
baseball yesterday giants did not play
so they will wear the number 42 as will
the marlins on the mount daniel castano
ready to roll
two and two is grounded to rojas it's
short and that's out number one
but donnie
as solano lines went out to center field
and making his final catch is starling
martay
i continue to rave about the first step
the jump the quickness that martay has
he gets the top speed about as well as
any centerfielder in the game
payoff pitch to yastripsky he's hit in
the air to right field
drifting back is duvall
he'll make the play and it's a one two
three inning for daniel costano disco
next now the marlins come up against
anthony diesclafani making his third
start with the giants he's been
excellent so far
slowly hit to solano
one out
and you got him
that hard breaking ball and there's the
first strikeout for disco finding
right to solano in a nice sitting for
disco fani he threw 10 pitches
up the middle and a base hit
and it's the first hit
in the game for the giants
first start here in 2021 a one-two pitch
is to jazz he'll lead rojas gets to the
back throws to first and it's picked by
cooper what a play wow are you kidding
me
everybody doing their job on that play
unbelievable now that is air rojas
and there's rojas up the middle
ah that's just a conventional play
seems so much better
there's crawford little bobble and with
the speed of chisholm will take it jazz
is on first with two out
crawford
short way
side retired
and he will get on for solano really
good at bat there work the count
quick snap and he threw it away this
could be three here
and it will be three years
[Music]
he's not going to get anything here a
fly ball out to center field for marte
and
there's a good sign
line drive base hit the other way for
jorge alfaro
two and two
got him
in the war
won by disco funny
he shook it off to the fastball
3-1 pitch here it is
swinging a drive to right down the line
a fair ball
it'll be devolved digging it out
yasrimski
digging into second and he's got a lead
off double that's just a great job right
there buddy
that's an easy scoring position
situation now for the giants longoria
drew a walk in the second
hit into left field a base hit
here comes jastremski giants are on the
board first it's one nothing
gloria comes up with his ninth rbi of
the year
and longo again has just been seeing the
ball so well all year
here's the 2-1
swinging a fly ball to ustremski
and that's called a shutdown inning for
anthony discovany fifth inning coming up
and on the hands
rolled to third
what are we at now ten ground ball ten
ground ball outs
and
jazz leads off
and this one is smoke to right low line
drop
top of the wall
jazz chasm with a home run
[Applause]
the impact this young man is having on
this marlin squad is let's go
it's not like anything i've seen in
quite some time especially for a
position player quality at bat after
quality at bat that is now a five game
extra base
streak that he's got going jazz chisholm
junior solo home run to right
and now rojas toward the left center
field gap
that is gonna get down and one off the
wall extra bases for miggy as he crews
into second
now the ball rattles away but he'll stay
put
got him and that'll end the inning came
back just enough
the damage is a run on the home run by
chisholm
kasrinsky fairball down the right field
line and he can run for a while
the ball is going to have to dig it out
and jazz is not going to stop
here's the throw to third not in time a
triple
getting just 148
and out to center field
marte will make the catch simber works
into and out of some trouble in the
sixth inning
[Music]
got him
[Music]
perfect yeah
you can tell the reaction you got there
i just didn't think
he was seeing the ball very well
dickerson over
adjust
and he caught it
grandpa right up against the wall puts
it away
and that's going to end the inning
3-1 from whistler on the way
and that's ball four
so the go-ahead run is on here in the
eighth
cape kepler making his way to the mound
and that might be it for whistling
0-1 to dickerson and dickerson serves
one out to left field to base hit
sierra up to second marlins half two on
in the inning
marlins oh for three with runners in
scoring position tonight they've been
good in those situations all year though
third best team
a
averages
deep left center field goodbye
three run over for starling martay
yeah you saved your best swing for your
fourth advantage of the night you get
declining out of there
and all of a sudden starlight marty
comes back
yeah he does first pitch he sees
[Music]
[Applause]
is a base unloads for garrett cooper
through longoria and crawford yimi
garcia brings it home and strikes him
out 95 miles an hour from garcia one
away
another 2-2 from garcia ground ball
that's anderson
across the diamond
it's a marlins win
thanks to a three-run homer from
starling marty in the last of the eighth
the marlins have taken the opener of
this three-game series from the giants